[Musik]
ein wunderschöner herbstabend erwartet
uns in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
hält meine lieben freunde fragt sich
wahrscheinlich mensch luca warum
erwartet uns kein schöner morgen heute
in deiner welt ja das hat etwas mit dem
titel zu tun wir sind nämlich schon
davon
ja deswegen habe ich auch schon ein
bisschen schiss ihr seht schon im titel
eingeblendet dass die heutigen episode
etwas mit phantomen zu tun hat deswegen
habe ich auch schon ein bisschen schiss
vor die sache ist allerdings dass mir
die kommentare geschrieben wurde dass
ich mir doch bitte für die ent folge
einen trank des sanften falls habe ich
mir aufgeschrieben dass ich mir einen
auf jeden fall machen soll weil ich
damit wenn ich vom ender drachen wohin
geschleudert werde keinen großen
unfallschaden bekommen beziehungsweise
gar keinen fall schaden ich weiß es
nicht ich hab noch nicht meiner test
welt getestet deswegen brauchen wir
dafür allerdings phantom heute denn
damit kann man nur den teil herstellen
und diese phantom heute bekommen wir
noch in phantome kommend phantome
bekommen man nur auf seine welt wenn man
es schafft drei tage lang in minecraft
nicht schlafen zu gehen ihr fragt euch
jetzt allerdings erstmal was unser
fertigen damit zu tun hat das tut mir
auch und in die kommentare geschrieben
und zwar luca bringen doch dann fährt
einfach auf seine trauer insel dann
kannst du nämlich ganz easy das pferd
einfach frei rumlaufen lassen denn hier
ist ja eh niemand angekettet ich hab so
schätzt dass in der heutigen folge in
die so noch zwei nächten mir denke es
wird dunkel ich geh jetzt mal schlafen
damit ich allerdings tatsächlich gar
nicht mal erst auf die idee komme werde
ich jetzt mein bettchen nehmen und das
einfach mal provisorisch hier hinstellen
und wir begeben uns nun auch auf eine
reise denn ich will auf gar keinen fall
diese drei nächte die ich überleben muss
damit die phantome kommen diese drei
nächte mich auf gar keinen fall die auf
meiner insel verbringen denn da sehe ich
schon wieder krach kommt schon erste
zombie ich lese hier auf unserer insel
schon kommen dass da unzählige creepers
born werden und skelette und zombies und
leute die uns eigentlich insel
kaputtmachen ist hier
ja genau das meine ich meine leute 2 max
480 da sind sogar zwei sich gerade
leute schreien wächst hier
ich habe euch das gerade mal an crd hier
drin gelassen natürlich
mein da unten dreht sich ein zombie
ich rief so oft kommentare von wegen er
luca dem sports die ganzen creeper doch
und 2000 sofort ihr habt jetzt mal
gesehen das ist ja wie caspar das ist
einfach eine reinste creeper map wir
können allerdings auch mal wieder ganz
kurze unserem kleinen stoner hier unten
gehen da wird allerdings auch wieder
nichts gesponsert einfach leider zu weit
von unserer web weg ist wo wir uns immer
aufhalten allerdings kann man ja
trotzdem mal ganz kurz eben schauen die
sache ist allerdings dass ich die drei
tage nicht ohne schlafen überleben
wollte auf meiner website war dann ist
da vorne irgendwie betrieb hat er
springt irgendwas ihnen luft ist auf der
anderen seite irgendwie nett was
irgendwelche tiere von uns tötet oder so
habe ich wirklich gar keinen bock drauf
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht dass wir
uns gemeinsam auf die suche nach balu
begeben
das wird mir nämlich auch und in die
kommentare geschrieben und zwar hat sich
da jemand die timelines angeguckt und
hat dann gesehen dass du anscheinend
irgendwo irgendwie irgendwann hängen
geblieben ist
direkt
3m an einem herzinfarkt wenn die
runterfallen eine stunde später
es ist schon
ein bisschen langweilig hier
und schaue ja ich würde sagen wir sehen
glaube ich selber anderen meiner
experience leisten das macht nicht so
mega viel sind jetzt die ganze nacht zu
verbringen deswegen werden wir uns jetzt
mal auf den weg begeben
wir werden jetzt mal versuchen meine
lieben freunde von euch eine ganz kurze
time lab
[Musik]
mein gott leute dadurch dass wir so oft
im bett mit dabei haben habe ich gar
nicht mehr diese sonnenaufgang so
richtig in minecraft von der position
aus gesehen sondern wenn man halt
schläft dann ist die sonne ja direkt
neben dem höheren ort schon aber wie
krass das einfach aussieht und wie sich
das hier rum zieht er das ist so
wundervoll mit diesem shader ich freue
mich auch schon so oft staffel 2 ich
weiß doch nicht vorne starten wird der
krieg ganz auf die frage gestellt in den
kommentaren weil einige auf meinen das
ende des jahres sogar 1.18 raus kommt
also aktuell spiele ich auf 1.16 1.17
ist schon draußen da kam eine menge
höhlen dazu und mit der 1.18 kommen eine
menge geile berge dazu dass er schon
sehr wild wenn man einen berg irgendwie
baut ganz viele ideen allerdings möchte
ich eigentlich nicht bis zum winter sind
erwarten deswegen leute warnt falls
irgendwer kontakt bei minecraft hat und
da irgendwie was genaueres weiß dann hat
es mich gerne in die kommentare oder
generell wofür ihr seid also 117 schon
starten oder 42 1.18 warten weil wenn
ich mit der 1.17 start
perfekt
wenn ich mit der 10 17 startet dann
bleibe ich halt auch eine 1.17 dann will
ich jetzt ach guck mal perfekt
die überreste unseres krieges naja wenn
ich mit der 1.17 starten würde also
irgendwie weiß ich nicht wann das dann
wäre vielleicht in einem monat oder zwei
oder drei ich muss man schauen wir nicht
dann mit der staffel 2 starte ich wollte
auf jeden fall mal kurz ein bisschen
pause machen mit minecraft
dann würde ich auch einen punkt zu
bleiben dann möchte ich nicht als meine
welt daneben einigen chancen irgendwie
anders generiert wird nur weil ich dann
auf die 1.18 switche allerdings falls
ihr da irgendwie was genaueres wissen
oder release dates oder irgendwelche
tipps habt oder soda generell auch
einschätzung auf die dinge selbst und
den kommentare es macht gar keinen sinn
dass hier zu groß durch das dorf laufe
weil er die will ja eh alle tot sind
weil ich den überfall nicht geschafft
habe die sache ist allerdings dass ich
ja mittlerweile jetzt hier angekommen
bin und ich definitiv von der seither
kam ich hab mir die letzte folge noch
mal angeguckt das war ja vor meinem
urlaub auf mallorca falls ihr da sehen
wollt was da so alles abgeben dann folgt
mir gern auf instagram er guckt da gern
mal vorbei ich heiße der laser luca und
da lohnt es sich auf jeden fall mehr zu
folgen weil ich jetzt auch ab donnerstag
wieder in köln bin menge unterwegs dann
bin ich nächste woche dienstag bei einem
champions-league-spiel ich derzeit alles
mit weil ich genau weiß dass irgendwann
das gros plötzlich wieder vorbei sein
kann aufgrund von email corona sachen
wer sich was deswegen habe ich gerade
absolut homo weiß gar nicht ob ich das
wort passt sagt das heißt wie fear of
missing out oder so das boarding wie bei
uns irgendwie so etabliert weil alle
meine freunde jetzt irgendwie alles
mitnehmen reisen und events und keine
ahnung was und ja man keine chance
auslassen will irgendwie was unternehmen
mit freunden seine leute zusehen und
familie zu sehen weil es irgendwie von
jetzt auf gleich bahn der iss vorbei
sein könnte ich mit meinem stück zu
vergeben ich hab gar noch total
eingemummelt irgendwie mit dem rudi der
tatsächlich dann auch passen zufolge 100
in den luca shop kommt dann muss ich
euch allerdings auch ganz kurz sagen und
währenddessen ich das sage guck ich mir
hier einfach mal irgendwo gesehen
ich muss euch ganz kurz sagen dass ja
dieser blaue rudi raus kommt noch ein
grüner sweater die sache ist allerdings
dass der grüne sweater dass man ihn erst
mal nur vorbestellen kann diesen holte
hier wenn man sich gegen kauf wird bei
denen direkt beliefert wird man direkt
beliefert mit dem who die bei den grünen
zweiter dauert allerdings noch ein
bisschen weil er halt von dem stoff und
von dem ganzen material her was neues es
wieder was wir gemacht haben deswegen
ich habe kein essen
wir haben ein problem
ich kann jetzt allerhöchstens tiere
töten und die essen ich hoffe einfach
mal dass wir bei you direkt treffen und
dass er vielleicht irgendwie hier unten
sitzt oder irgendwo hier festgehangen
ist oder was weiß ich was weil da hinten
war schon der überfall dass er jetzt
irgendwo hier in dem gebiet muss er ja
sein und da kann ich ihnen auch einfach
mal suchen ohne zu sprinten ganz kurz
noch mal auf das merge thema einzugehen
neues merchandiser an alle die es in den
letzten folgen eventuell nicht
mitbekommen haben sollten und jeder der
auch bock auf nazis habe den könnt ihr
das erklärt vielleicht mehr schreiben es
kommt nur zwei neue sachen raus
allerdings pünktlich zufolge 100 könnt
ihr die sachen bestellen lieferzeit ist
ein bisschen länger könnte ein zwei
wochen dauern aufgrund der tatsache dass
wir die sachen nicht so schnell
produziert kriegen ihr wissen wir
produzieren in italien aufgrund der
qualität und ja die neuen stoffe und so
lässt alles ein bisschen die zu besorgen
deswegen ist unser plan auf jeden fall
dass ihr die sachen zwar vorbestellen
könnt wenn folge 100 rauskommt das wird
irgendwann hab' mal so angepeilt zehnter
oktober zwar zehnter 10 dafür nicht ein
ganz cooles daten
[Musik]
das kannst du jedoch wieder nicht
ausdenken da sitzt bei louis einfach rum
und
durch schon sagen ich weiß allerdings
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht genau warum ich
überhaupt bei dir sitzt gemacht habe
weil das war eigentlich eine time labs
wie ich hier hingefahren bin
beziehungsweise ja keine ahnung ob ich
dann irgendwie beim bruder paul auster
den rechtsweg gedrückt habe aber jetzt
müsste er theoretisch mitkommen weil ich
hatte auch erst gedacht als ich dachte
bei lewis irgendwie weg oder so dachte
ich halt leider erst das irgendwie
gestorben sein aber das wird man ja
krieg der im chat angezeigt wenn der
eigene hund stirbt steht dann irgendwie
ja wurde von dem skript erschossen oder
irgendwie sowas allerdings stand es dort
nicht und ich dachte mir okay dann muss
er halt irgendwo chillen oder
festgehangen sein aber jetzt haben aber
nur auf jeden fall gefunden und können
dann der stelle ich uns jetzt auch nach
hause bewegen die sache ist allerdings
dass wir erst eine nacht überlebt haben
und wir müssen drei nächte überleben ich
weiß nicht ob wir zwei nächte erleben
müssen und in der dritten nacht kommen
dann die phantome das könnte ich mal
ganz kurz in google und
die phantome kommen nach drei nächten in
denen der spieler nicht geschlafen hat
das heißt jetzt nach drei nächten
während wir hierzulande marsch ich
zurück laufen weil ich kein essen
mitgebracht haben er ist einfach so
jetzt geht so viel schief während ich
jetzt hier auf jeden fall zurück laufen
würde ich sagen kann ich euch mal ein
bisschen schon mal erklären was die
phantome überhaupt sind und zwar erstmal
bei lukas prozent ein mittelprächtiger
phantome sind nämlich und rote kreaturen
daher werden sie durch heiltränke
geschädigt durch schadens tränke geheilt
und erhalten mehr schaden durch mit
bahnen verzauberte waffen also merke
atome sind und rot wir machen kleinen
test
machen wenn ich komme sicher dass schule
sie brennen im sonnenlicht und nehmen
schaden okay das heißt dass phantome
wahrscheinlich wirklich in der nacht
spawnen dementsprechend da dort steht
sie kommen nach drei nächten heißt das
wahrscheinlich sie kommen in der dritten
nacht ich denke jetzt nicht dass sie
dann in der vierten nacht plötzlich
kommen oder so also ich glaube wir
müssen noch eine nacht überleben es ist
gerade mittag das heißt die hälfte der
episode haben wir quasi durch und danach
kommen die phantome und sie verfügen
außerdem über eine eigenschaft namens
sei es mit denen ihre größe beliebig
verändert werden kann
das heißt es kann sein dass ein ganz
kleines und um kommt aber auch ein
risiko ist
okay weiter geht es im programm phantome
können nicht ertrinken genau wie alle
anderen untoten kreaturen sie bewegen
sich im wasser wie durch locken
das heißt ob die im wasser oder in der
luft sind die fliehen die ganze zeit
schnell rum
falls sie übrigens nicht wissen wie ihr
werdet ihr sehen wie phantome aussehen
von daher ist es auch relativ egal wir
merken uns also ein phantom hat genauso
viel leben wie ich und macht
wahrscheinlich auch genau so viel
schaden wie ich deswegen wird es ein
ausgeglichener kampf die sache ist nur
dass ich nicht genau weiß wie viele
phantome kommen werde und da habe ich
ein bisschen schiss vor weil es kann
natürlich sein dass da 0 1 kommen
und dann habe ich ein problem da man
wirklich großes problem von daher
abwarten und tee trinken
schon lange kennt hier getrunken haben
wir gar keinen bock mehr auf t nachdem
hier jeder x-beliebige rapper plötzlich
seinen haft oder dirty oder braten
rausgebracht
ich bringe einfach ein leuchtturm im
supermarkt muss also zehn millionen euro
könnt euch den garten stellen da ich
jetzt nicht die nacht auf meiner
hauptinsel verbringen wollte wo bei
meinem glück wieder 70.000 milliarden
trillionen krieg an die luft geflogen
werden hab ich dich einfach auf ein paar
umliegenden inseln von mir verbracht ein
bisschen gechillt bisschen auch kämpft
gegen andere monster und dabei zu oft
geredet habe ich ganz viel langweiligen
und
jetzt machen wir weiter sobald die nacht
hier vorbei war es ist so wundervoll
diese ganzen farbene
das kann ich nicht oft genug sagen
[Musik]
indem ich getroffen hätte
ich wäre einfach gestorben ballouz jetzt
noch da hinten im boot drin ich kann ja
jetzt allerdings gerade auch nicht hin
laufen und ich weiß allerdings auch dass
der typ mit diesem fackeln mit diesen
mistgabeln dass apple nicht attackieren
wird ich muss mich jetzt erst mal
aufpassen dass hier keine monster sind
deswegen gehe ich erst mal ganz kurz
nach hier oben jetzt eh niemand drin und
jetzt schauen wir uns erst mal ganz kurz
hier ein bisschen um sind hier irgendwo
skelette oder irgendwas weit ich muss
wirklich zu meinem essen da unten sind
die bienen von daher werde ich mich
jetzt erstmal ganz fixieren bewegen und
hier haben wir nichts mehr drin weil es
jetzt alles unten drin ist allerdings
kann ich mir theoretisch hier direkt
erstmal ein bisschen weizen holen mit
dementsprechend dadurch brote machen so
dass ich mir zumindest ein bisschen was
zu essen geben machen kann und schon mal
ein bisschen meine hält aufladen kann
hier unten ist niemand drin hier ist
allerdings auch nicht so richtig krass
toll gewachsen außer dass weizen hier so
ein bisschen das nämlich jetzt auch noch
mal ganz schnell leben und jetzt machen
wir uns erst mal fix 7 brote mit denen
wir unser leben zumindest ein bisschen
wieder auffüllen können die wache ist
dass ich wie ich schauen muss wie ich
das am ende mache das könnt ihr auch
gerne in die kommentare schreiben das
sieht allerdings glaube ich dass ich
dann wirklich auch fleisch zurückgreifen
werde weil es am meisten hielt und ich
dementsprechend davon auch am meisten
habe das ist nämlich ausnahmen wissen
dass dinge gehen langsam die natürlichen
ressourcen dem ende entgegen weil ich an
meine farbe die zu beginn ja so riesig
war da dachte ja das reich weil ich halt
niemand sagt er glaubt nicht
dass ein fixer also du mal bitte kurz
hier zurück rhein zu valencia gab alois
war auf jeden fall schön aufzug mit dir
das verblüfft gewesen dass du dich dann
eben wo dahin gesetzt hast allerdings
hier für dich auf jeden verein fleisch
und valencia ein fleischgericht sie noch
ein zweiter sogar noch ein zweites weil
er wahrscheinlich immer sogar auch noch
hunger hat wegen der dings sachen oder
wegen der mistgabeln die abbekommen hat
hier vorne habe ich auf jeden fall noch
ein bisschen was drin schaue ich mal
vielleicht aber noch eins
und noch eins gebrauchen kann meine
lieben freunde und dann muss ich euch
tatsächlich auch zum ersten mal eine
richtige timeline länder in der ich
jetzt nichts machen werde hier kommen ja
noch eins gestern immer noch keine
herzen darüber
empfehlungen hat er denn also valencia
braucht keins mehr und balu auch nicht
okay das heißt beide sind auf jeden fall
durch ich werde jetzt mal eben ganz kurz
meine items sortieren und euch dabei
auch eine teilnetz einblenden wie ich
hier mal alles auf vordermann bringen
werde ich werde mir die ganzen knochen
mal eben holen als der skelett fahren
hier alles fertig machen so dass wir so
ein bisschen natürliches essen hat für
die nächsten folgen zumindest noch mal
und ja dann sehen wir uns wieder
wenngleich nacht ist und hoffentlich die
phantom is born
[Musik]
okay leute ist macht es
ist nacht
und ich hab fast noch nichts zu essen ok
jetzt haben wir wirklich ein problem ich
musste
ich weiß ich habe ich mich geirrt habe
und dass ein falsches geräusch wahr was
ich mir da eingebildet habe aber ich
weiß nicht ob ich gut ausgerüstet wie
ich habe zwar mein schwert ich habe
meinen bogen mit stärke ich habe auf dem
totenschein bei plus ich habe auch noch
eine ein schild dabei und ich muss jetzt
auch noch mal ganz schnell die
kartoffeln im ofen backen die links
ebenso dass wir uns dann von hier oben
das ganze spektakel erst mal anschaue
mein gott ich dachte schon geführt
ich bin auch so schreckhaft wir dürfen
jetzt auf gar keinen fall schlafen gehen
deswegen werde ich jetzt einfach mal
dieses match direkt ab das ist ja nicht
aus versehen rechts ich mache ich kenne
mich
mich ja
ich weiß nicht ob ich dumm bin
ob ich mir grad wieder irgendein
geräusch eingebildet habe
aber geht es jetzt schon los
ist das erst in der nächsten nacht zeit
seit letztem ausruhen 0,93 stunden da
muss auf jeden fall eine eins stehen das
heißt es wird gleich so weit sein so
meine lieben freunde die kartoffeln sind
alle durchgebraten ich werde jetzt
einmal die tür aufmachen ich habe vorhin
schon zombie gehört dass wegen der
richtung habe zudem auch schützt dass
sie irgendwie herumläuft der eisen kohle
schild dann nur es kann jederzeit soweit
sein dass die phantome spawnen und ich
werde jetzt auch noch mal mir ganz kurz
eben hier ein bisschen eisen rausholen
so dass ich den eisen kohle eventuell
mit auf meine seite kriege da vorne
kommt ein zombie an den habe ich auf
jeden fall gerade gehört ich werde die
ich da hinten chilton schlieper
hoffentlich den von den eisen kunden
auch davon überzeugen
ich werde hoffentlich den einwohnern
davon überzeugen kann dass er auch mit
ein bisschen mithilft gegen die phantome
ich weiß allerdings nicht ob der die
realisiert als feind
das war die ganze ja
ich habe echt schiss also ich habe
vorhin noch mal bevor ich gesagt habe so
leute und bevor die kartoffel fertig war
ich noch mal geschaut und wir sind
wirklich bei mittlerweile einer stunde
angekommen und wenn sich jetzt ein
phantom nähert dann auf jeden fall mir
gegenüber weil ich das schlafdefizit
habe jetzt hier heute auch noch mal ein
ganz großer time lab suite basic lehrer
für die ganze zeit geangelt hat
nebenbei habe ich ein bisschen aber im
handy gechillt und einfach die zeit
nach thann geworden ist so meine lieben
freunde ich habe jetzt gerade hier die
ganze zeit geangelt eine menge fische
hier anstatt geholt pack dass jetzt mal
das jahr eine angel namensschild auch
eine wasserflasche das also nebenbei
gemacht und war dann auch ein handy o2
deswegen auch die angeln immer wieder
rein und hier hatte ich glaube ich die
fackeln ich werde mich jetzt auf jeden
fall mein brötchen setzen hätte sich die
schildkröten hier in jedem scheiß bot
vermieterin sitzen das echte frechheit
ich möchte nämlich dass das mit dem
phantom nicht auf meiner insel
stattfindet ich weiß wir haben uns also
ein bisschen drüber informiert und ich
glaube nicht dass die explosions schaden
anrichten ich will natürlich trotzdem
nicht dass ich in form von thom weglaufe
und dann kommt irgendwie par und
explodiert irgendwie ich habe auch
gerade mal in den statistiken geguckt
ich bin auf jeden fall schon länger als
eine stunde 20 jetzt an wach sein also
12 stunden das ist ja nicht eine stunde
20 minuten sondern eine stunde zehn
minuten er ca allerdings ist es jetzt
auf jeden fall an der freaks hier
[Musik]
aber gut
ist jetzt auch egal freundinnen wir
wollen uns ja heute um das phantom
kümmern
ich weiß nicht ob das hier in
ausreichender platz ist mit dem phantom
aufzunehmen ich weiß wenn ich hab nur
ein phantom kommen wird oder zwei oder
fünf oder keine ahnung was abgeht ich
bin auf jeden fall gut ausgestattet ich
habe essen ich habe einen bogen ich habe
einen diamant schwert um eine rüstung
auch noch mehr oder weniger vorhanden
von daher kommt
jetzt mal langsam
das grenzt ja schon an
arbeitsverweigerung hier von den
phantomen mittlerweile zweiter sind
jahre später er ich bin ganz ehrlich
es ist jetzt schon wieder fast die
hälfte der nacht um und hier kommt kein
phantom
was macht nicht falsch
bitte schreibt sie wohnen in die
kommentare
das ist die einzige auf meine insel
competition in die kommentare was ich
falsch mache meine lieben freunde ich
weiß nicht warum ich das ist jetzt
mittlerweile die vierte nacht in der ich
wach bin meine schlafenszeit in der ich
nicht geschlafen habe befindet sich
mittlerweile bei 1,4 stunden und im
wikipedia steht dass die nach einer
stunde schon kommen die folge hier läuft
auch schon wieder seit eineinhalb
stunden also ich weiß nicht was ich noch
alles machen sollte ich muss jetzt mal
langsam beenden wenn es euch gefallen
hat dann das gerne wie bisher wie es
läuft ein daumen hoch oder video hier
daneben ein kanal und liegt auf die
leute wenig nächste manchmal gar nicht
verpassen wollten schreibt mir zudem
bitte gern weiterhin tipps fürs ende und
in die kommentare und auch was sich hier
mit dem phantom hier mache jetzt einfach
nur noch so an der stelle starten
nächste folge weiter bis übermorgen
[Musik]